Lahr nach der Player
Spieltag der 2
Red Cat Ballou Rossiter
schön dass du hier bist ja
danke
freu mich auch Nachbar sein
Leben ja ich finde zu sein
vor allem nimmt diesen
sensationellen haben
das entspannt
wie ist die Lage
da könnten
Prozent Einfuhr
das ist eine Frage
nach der Lage
Mesum eine persönliche oder de
der Nationen der
Bill Cosby Show neue
Firmengeschichte
es ist Prozent hat sich
entscheiden feiern können
der Akteur
das liege etwa die andere als
erwartet werden am Herzen auch
die Welt liegt mir am Herzen
den Aufenthalt machen beim Thema
die Valad er selbst an einem
neuen Album
wobei er einmal genannt
Lektionen in Demut
jetzt elf und neun
elf Punkte 0 wobei sich die
elfte Version
Nein die zweite die ja
aber im Jahr 11 erschienen
die andere mal im Jahr 1 genau
10 zehn Jahre später als
ältere Fekter feige die
Geschichte erneut und doch
irgendwie neu obwohl die
gleichen Texte sind
mit anderen Musik ein
neuer Film
Dachser schon mal dass ein
Künstler
ca ein Album gemacht hat mit dem
neuen Wagen dessen aber
namentlich in mir ist da nichts
bekannt unter zehn Litern Leute
auch darauf reagiert das ist
einmalig oder erstmalig in der
Geschichte
danach kann auch aufgekommen so
lange sind die einfachsten Ideen
die noch niemand hatte
indem Verbilligung der erste
Jahrgang hat eine arabische
schlechte Idee wer kann die
andere eine neue Idee du dich
nicht und Liev Schreiber waren
Eigentor war Tillich habe auch
neue Ideen her
die hinterm Haus entdeckt
dazu kommen wir später also
nicht jetzt in dieser Sendung
sind viel später
wenn jetzt aber der
Treckerfahrer er aber warum
zum einen ist es
Aden Konzept da muss mir sehr am
Herzen liegt die Geschichte ist
so
dicht Binz schief
sie halte
diese eine Geschichte ohne diese
vielen Geschichte ist im
Einvernehmen spielen Siemens
gleiche Thema dringe welchen am
Rande und Reflektor Falke
reflektiert die Situation hält
uns den Spiegel vor und zeigt
uns diese Welt mit Superhelden
zum bewilligten
das Ding wird nicht alt
leider kam es daher zu sagen wer
schönen und drüber lachen
könnte sagte Altegoer bei
Wettbewerben Unterlage ab
bei der Haustür geklopft Nein
dem ist nicht so
es ist aktueller denn je aber
auch dass es dafür ausgebe
Sachen die wie leider darauf
soll
Missstände hinweisen sind immer
aktuell
mir geht es so dass ich dachte
so ein Album aufzunehmen
und
vielleicht ist es an der Zeit
zehn Jahre später nachdem ich
die Musik von Alex Kroll gehört
hat die mich sehr inspiriert hat
und die mehr
diesen überhaupt ist diesen
Gedanken hat
Do gebracht hat
Damerow dass die Musik von ihnen
werden solo- Album gearbeitet zu
der Zeit spielte seine Tracks
fort
und ich denke dass wie im Film
sie sollen
Kopfkino
Heesters auch mal gemacht da ist
auch mal so ein Film in deinem
Kopf zwar Effekte feige Lektion
in Demut
Porsche leichtes beschlossen in
Kellenhusen Zellmann zehn Jahre
alten Paul Kuhn vom ätzen
zehnjährigen vielleicht zum EMC
machen
Ziel dieser französische
NOR schwarz-weiß er Schwarz
Film
der prozentuale Hollywood
Effekte und Bruce Willis
Ausgaben aber mittlerweile
espoo/berlin Sprung Zagreb
unter den etwa der Weg ja auch
überall zu finden
der Schaden am Auto aber normal
großes Kino
und alle kreuzen erfolgreicher
Produzent den Dow
Med also letztlich hat sich die
Musik dazu inspiriert die Texte
weil seine Musik hat mich
inspiriert Liedtexter nochmal zu
bringen ja
wobei sondern bei
l weil sich an dieser Firma
diesen Film Aspekt und
was ich geil finde es nicht wie
mich überhaupt nicht gegen das
Original aus Sprenger seines
Porsche Isora mir gefällt's
nicht mehr über das hat damit
gar nichts zu tun
die gleichen Worte
dieser neuen Musik geben ein
neues Gefühl
und es erstaunlich ist eine
Salome dass das ist weder der
Gruppierung wird
Bucht nach zum ihres Tieres Song
ist absolut eigenständig UN hat
und das ist vielleicht
auch das entscheidende
Sonova Hamme und so viel Licht
und den Arm nehmen in der Musik
werde der Typ nach wie vor den
Kopf wäscht oder das Gehirn
und die sagt dass hier alles so
manches
nimmt sich die Musikerinnen
der nationale Rundfunk - fast
schon geschafft hast du es ja es
ist Schall sie gewesen wäre
wir kommen an an diesen
nächsten Tag durch diese lange
Nacht und dass alte Album war
der Staat der ohne Zeigefinger
mit einer
gedruckt mit dem mit der Warnung
weder offen ausgesprochenen
Warnung
passt auf Florian wird verarme
emotional wir gehen unter
und das auf allen Ebenen
und dass neue ist so
überlässt ihr viel mehr
die Entscheidung was du machst
nach dieser Platte hinten
rauskommt Sinn der erste
Sonnenstrahl diese lange Nacht
beendet und du hast es in der
Hand eines ist
gibt mir Hoffnung das gefällt
mir sehr gut dabei
weil das alte Angreifer bewusst
Steinfeld
so sagt er das war ein tritt
ja es ist immer schwer zu sagen
warum hat man das wie gemacht er
um es gibt Jobs Connecting the
Dots wer könnte denn die Rede
der gehaltenen im Nachhinein
Krugsdorf Punkte und Saskia klar
Super alles richtig gemacht oder
hol dich hier vielleicht anders
in dem Moment wo du machst
machst du
und so ist es erste Album
entstanden so ist auch das Album
entstanden aus und floh aus dem
kreativen Schaffensprozess und
dann kommt ließ genauso wie
Duke retrospektiv an und sagten
Kialka Wyman damals ziemlich
sie empfiehlt drehen
jetzt hatte ich vielleicht mehr
Abstand aber gleichzeitig
interessant ist auch dass ich
dem Album wahnsinnig entstand
gegenüber
normalerweise in äußerungen ab
bin ich total auf Geräte mit
allen sagen ist es besser sie je
gemacht haben hier und so
und dieses mal bis zur 11
denn mit Assists zehn Jahre alte
ist jetzt kein
dickes Ding aber es ist
natürlich
nach wie vor
sehr wichtig mir sehr wichtig
aber ich muss es keinen
verkaufen
wird solch ein
Pätzold nicht anbieten konnte
und noch was ihr wollt dabei
sind der FIL kra
natürlich an den Kräften
und auch in der Musik ist es
schon BBC
und die Texte waren ebenso
wichtig dass man sagt ich musste
noch etwas ein
Bild beim Doktor Faustus greifen
vielleicht so weiß er es ist
auf jeden Fall ein Kapitel in
meinem Leben müsste
Fisher
wie gesagt ich hab so was nicht
wieder machen das ist dumm
ich bekannt dass am besten
beschreiben einem Beispiel
Krieger Song ferner fand das den
er nicht gemacht das hat so die
neunmonatige darüber wie die
Geburt
welche Leute die sich nicht an
für und er ein
Kucka mit damit auseinandersetzt
denke ich auch so Robby hast du
das machen wie wirst du das
geschrieben keine Ahnung mehr
wie Test geschrieben habe
in dem Moment durch die
Schwimmer Boss klar
jedes Wort jeder Buchstabe war
klar es gibt nur diesen einen
Buchstaben an diese eine Stelle
Denise mein Bauch sagt ein muss
und so ist sie bei dem ganzen
Album indem Prozess war das
alles klar als er heute noch dem
Film ich hab diese
Bilder zum Kopf
aber ich würd's nicht wieder
machen
weil es ist ja da
ein und es neu aufzulegen nach
zehn Jahren es schon
vielleicht verläuft wie das
erste gar nicht mitgekriegt
haben Kindes zu sperrig war zu
dunkel
um die noch zu Jung waren oder
noch nicht geboren
die können jetzt sowie
einsteigen und sagen okay
und Musik
wie waren oder die Musik geben
so gut zu machen wie sie ist
möchtest du vielleicht eine
Botschaft auch wenn er sagt ich
bin entspannt unter mehr Leute
bringen ist
ich sehr gerne
Schirmherr Hofläden Ballack
erfolgte er tatsächlich klar
der andere die Musik außen
jetzt zu nehmen also gehen wir
jetzt auch stattfinde de
elektronisch wobei das dingliche
elektronische Rückhalt klingt
sondern sehr
organisch und um der Motion
Allah ist
aber trotzdem ich finde es ist
eine Musik die jetzt gerade
mich ist jetzt aber die Stadt
findet die ihm jetzt stattfindet
unterm ermöglicht dem anderen
vielleicht ihr den Einstieg
in diese Welt dann ist es mehr
recht also je mehr Leute das
würde mit kriegen das schon
nicht mehr zu erreichen und
diese Welt eine Welt der
Superhelden
die nicht mit der Welt hadert
der oder weniger vor allem
Reflektor Fall der Simpson
Antiheld so ein klassischer
er ist eben so gestrandet auf
dem Planeten Erde aber auf dem
Planeten sehen Regens
und er reflektiert alles sehr
nimmt den Leuten ihre Masken ab
erhält in den Spiegel vor und
sie sehen in ihm ihr wahres
Gesicht
was natürlich vieles zufolge
hat zum einen
ist es nicht unbedingt angenehm
was du das siehst zum andern
erkennst du auch dein gegenüber
nicht als das was er ist und es
ist nun Reflektion von deiner
Einstellungen seiner Sichtweise
in dem anderen
und es ändert sich alles
Sachen die wir auf dieser Welt
genauso stattfinden
die ihm dem
dem Helden dem tragischen Helden
nicht gefallen gemacht ihn auch
nicht glücklich
weil es sind im schlechtesten
Falle sei König der Narren wie
der Hof NADA als einzige die
Wahrheit sagen darf über die
man lacht vielleicht und dann
will ich nicht hören weil die
Wahrheit Psych
Schoon angenehm ist
«Beides ist nicht schön er
Worte oder
Schmeicheleien sind die Mandeln
sie dulde wird
und so um
aber auch er mit seinem
Schicksal was dann aber bei
Lektion in Demut bei dem
sie versorgt
dazu führte
er trifft den wandernden
Wissenschaftlern der wandernde
Wissenschafter zwingt den
Reflektor Falten
sich mit sich selbst zu
reflektieren keinen anderen mehr
keine Ausreden mehr nicht die
sind Schuld und der hat aber
soll 2
wer bist du
vielleicht alles entscheidende
Frage
und nachdem er sich selbst
erkennt sein Innerstes Wesen
wird er und das ist vielen
unklar auch Leuten die sich
damit vielleicht
auseinandergesetzt am Zoo
aber Kaiser Superstar zu der
zum Wesen aus Rheine n-ergie zu
einem Wesen das natürlich auch
außerhalb unserer
Moralvorstellung existiert weil
wenn wir von Gott
von und göttlichen Wesen
sprechen können ist eher
Geburt und Tod
er ist der den ich am Schluss
wurde der der dir das da sein
gibt er ist
im Team
ist alles was wir gut und
Scheiße finden vereint ja es
kann nicht sein dass Prozent
nur das gute ist und wenn keine
Kontrolle hat über das böse
was also wenn es
«Wenn man das glaubt an eine
höhere Instanz sein eine
allumfassende Einheit Prozent an
hat die Tempi Inhalte die alles
nicht nur das sondern damit dass
noch mehr erhofft
Westerhoff nur für uns in
diesen schwierigen Zeiten
denn am Ende frei zu dich
nun geht das alles Rinke diese
Meldung die Pollen was ist los
und so
und dann muss so glaube ich
kannst du darauf zurückkommen
sagen okay wenn zum Plan gibt
dann ist das auch Teil des Plans
dann ist das Teil der
Entwicklung von uns allen
des Planeten
dass Menschen der Seele des
Bewusstseins was auch immer das
muss wir müssen da durch
ansonsten kann Sorg am
verzweifeln
stark drogenabhängig werden
aber immer gern auch einfach
sagen können ist dass die
Prüfungen dann
sind es die Lektion in Demut
Bartz noch weder auf den Punkt
die Fakten auch geheime
überzeugung
nächste völlig nur so weil
sich das gut verkauft
Bayer habe eine sehr getragen
würden sagte sie am
attraktivsten Comic Punkten lag
man muss ja nicht
dann nimmt man muss ja nicht
hundertprozentig dahinter stehe
man kann ja ein Kunstwerk
schaffen
einen Aspekt Prozent darstellt
wie man nicht unbedingt vertritt
aber gemach irgendwo
die Spinne Fekter weiter
mehr das ist eine gute Frage
kann man Kunst machen wenn man
an sie eigentlich nicht vertritt
Ode ist Kunst nur dann Kunst
wenn sie ein Teil
das Innerste des Dassower außen
kein Weg der das Feld
möchte sich beantworten
aber ich kann dazu nur sagen ich
habe tatsächlich sehr dass er
jetzt meint emotional
ängstlicher Blick auf unsere
Welt natürlich ja natürlich
ist diese comic-geschichte und
diese
eigene Welt und zuweilen
zugebilligte Nomacorc
fortführen
mein Gefühl das sie auf dem
Planeten passiert und
zum einen zehn Jahre alt oder
älter
zum anderen sich immer noch das
gleiche
unten im o-ton Ahler Blick
Tel was medial Lösung bis 10%
dem Weg dahin gelenkt hat es ist
kein Promi Problem das wir haben
kein politisches Problem kann
ich mal privat es ist ein
emotionales Problem richtig
das sinnliche bei ich glaube auf
dem Planeten SE wegen ich weiß
bisher Blanik Wesseling links
das ist das Ende der Harmonie
und jede Menschlichkeit
nee das ist das Ende der
pulsierende ihre Menschlichkeit
der Tote Harmony noch durch zu
koppeln dieser Zeit
das den nicht trifft ziemlich
genau es ist möglich
denn keine
was macht uns aus als Mensch
das definiert uns als Menschen
und dar
denn die vielen hilft diese
Fürsorge wenn wir das
wenn wir dies Mitgefühl
verlieren
dann werden werden wir das Kind
menschliche uns dann entfernen
wir uns freuen
unserem eigentlichen
Prozent unserer Aufgabe
auf diesem Planeten
es gibt ja Leute seien völlig
total gut
als in der Bibel stand macht
euch die Erde Untertan es ist
ein übersetzungsfehler uns
reißt eigentlich macht bricht
der Erde Untertan
genau das ist der feine oder
Visia TM überragend wie verwies
Oriol die verringerten kleine
Aldi Glauber auch wenn dieses
irgendwas gesagt wäre dann eher
WS ihr seid
die Prozent mehr
dieser dafür da um der Erde zu
dienen
Aigner nutzte die ja auch nicht
anders wie wir immer mehr stellt
fest welche einfach nicht
möglich Lack jeder damals getan
hast» den Weichen Boden ab
aber es gibt in Mali ist es
kommt immer zurück
Nein man das dann
in Bremen
alles tun als einen reinen einen
einen Gesamt Prozent
nebenbei wird man sehen
Müller fast sagen du vertrittst
du könntest auch da verzweifelt
wie was machen damit sie nicht
angezweifelt
um
Na ja wie gesagt wenn das Teil
das der Prüfung ist ein
Prozente muss das sein wir
müssen das erleben es wird
schon nichts passieren und so
positiv
du denkst es geht ihm gut aus
nee das würde ich nicht
unbedingt unterschreiben ich
weiß nie wie es ausgeht dann
erlebte ich das noch nicht
gelesen Goldberg
das Buch nicht hinten angefahren
aber
Alber sich auch letzte Starterin
guter Gedanke der mir dann kam
dachte ich werden
Altersteilzeit Leben wir wie
wenig Leute haben
dieses Vergnügen
und dieses zweifelhafte
Vergnügen das jetzt mit zur EM
2012 zu erleben über das so
viel gesprochen wird
den Hoffnungen in Angst und
überhaupt wer diesen radikalen
Wandel der auf dieser Weltstadt
für das erkennen
das ist so nicht weitergeht
zu krasse Veränderungen dient
uns in den nächsten Jahren
Prozent ins Haus fallen das
das ist schon auch und selbst
wenn man davon ausgehen würde
das geht nicht weil das ist
alles noch mal so wir werden
alle sterben
dann sind wir die letzten die
das erlebt am Gerät
weiß dass keine Auszeichnung
ist Irnich eine Auszeichnung
alle anderen
es kann immer wieder immer
wieder näher z
kommt der letzte Akt
und wir sind alle Teil dieses
großartigen Schauspiels Buch es
ist zumindest was Wert in dieser
Zeit zu Leben
aber 5
Ach ja schon einige Packungen
wenn man eher in ins Auge fassen
sie ihm schlecht ausgeht die
ganze Geschichte her also
weniger als zehn Jahre ein
neunziger Jahren haben wir ja
eigentlich immer geglaubt Hey
das wird alles besser die
Grünen Friedensbewegung weniger
Atomwaffen wird immer alles
besser aber es gab im
pfälzischen Faltin Lupe heftige
Prozent wuchs Schläge dass man
in Verden die besser
die Leute
m lassen sie bestechen und
machen und welche ganz
schrecklichen Sachen oder mit
dem Bollerwagen können oder
oder oder ja in was für einer
Welt Leben die Revierinhaber
auch nur eine Verstärkung
dieser ganzen Geschehnisse gibt
es die Chance sie aus diesem
Kreislauf zu lösen weil wir
wissen es alle was zu sagen es
uns gut geht und es geht uns gut
da muss man es auch nicht
wirklich
er merkt der Keiler nicht daheim
17 mal an Tagen Vollbad nehmen
neben den kümmert's Duell wenn
er kein Wasser mehr aus um das
sieht man dann fängst du an
umzudenken
scheinbar müssen wir natürlich
auch um das in der Heftigkeit
erfahren
der deutsche ist ja noch
sehr schnell bereit um zu denken
und zu lernen auch Wenzel die
rein nicht selber passiert
sondern man sieht's auf der Welt
darin besteht wieder Hoffnung
das wird eng
ich hab den angepeilten Gewinn
ab Homburger Comeback gab
das heißt ja immer ein sehr
erfahrener
aber all das für das wenn er
das dicht so tauften sichtlichen
zu offensichtlich Schmiere im
Theater und und Puppenspiel habe
ich in der Politik selber noch
nicht erlebt
also vielleicht gibts anderen
auch so dieser Quelle
allerdings geben der bisher
glaubt Milito Vierzylinder
Helmut Sommer auf und damit
könnte auch sie wieder zu
ändern
- Trainer Alexei Shirov Ei
al
das Kind verloren wobei die auf
der Grenze zwischen Verzweiflung
und der Verzweiflung
oder Wut der Verzweiflung
ja es ist um
zum ein Jahr nicht gut
angefangen schon mein Vater
verloren
und es lässt dann nochmal 000
qm Tod und Leben nachdenken und
dann hat meine Familie ich bin
meinem Fall mit dort zwei
Kindern den Dirty auch in
Zukunft will nicht
allerdings ist schon normal
anders aber das
ändert die Gewichtung und die
Wertigkeit von vielem
und das ist eigentlich gut dass
man einigen der Prozess
und am Ende führt dazu
den Augenblick mehr zu schätzen
denn wir wissen alle um die
Vergänglichkeit das selbigen
und
trotzdem glauben die meisten es
gebe immer so weiter rechnet
ganz alt und glückliche mein
Bett sterben und das werden die
wenigsten
von Amanda Server realisierten
sagt okay ist gibt diese
Sicherheit nicht die gab's noch
nie wir haben sie also immer
schön einreden lassen oder
selber eingeredet aber wenn wir
dich damit auseinandersetzt
und du wirklich dann weiter zu
gehen
damit können
wenn es Morgen zu Ende ist ein
Fenster mit jeden Augenblick zu
Ende sein könnte was da auf
jeden von uns so trifft
dann wirds Wetter Mahlzeit den
ganzen
dieses ganz simpel haben das
ganze um unnötige
den Müll aber auch wirklich
den Kopf frei zu machen und sich
um die wesentlichen
sich mit
irgendwie sind wir alle auf der
Sinn suchen dennoch können was
die Leute
ich habe aufhören können weil
sie müssen sie haben ihre
eigene Existenz gewann sie
müssen
Bryant billige Lebensmittel
einkaufen weil sie können sich
keine guten leisten und so
weiter und so fort
Prozent sie werden sich keine
Elektronen Auto leisten können
weil das Cockpit über
fünfzigtausend Euro
und so weiter und so fort die
können das Alter in dem man
anmerkt dass man oft denkt
Prozent wo ist der Ausweg ist
gibt er keinen Ausweg
es gibt fünf Millimetern Ausweg
Marcel sie können dann in die
Eifel sehen und auch
Einbürgerung für Leoni
diese Möglichkeit habe er
weniger oder örtlich kann es
sein dass sie glauben sie nicht
diese Möglichkeit haben
also nehmen sie auch
widersprechen möchte ich meinem
Kumpel den Braker 35 tausend
Euro gekostet also nochmal
Glück gehabt Deutschland
deutlich billiger
und wer eher Fahrt auch Autos
die Geld gekostet haben der
rundum
das mit der gesunden Ernährung
Essen auch ein eindeutiges
Vorteil scheint wohl ist
wesentlich teurer
wenn man zum Beispiel
anfängt
aufreißen Zustands nicht gutes
Währungskrise Beispiel mit dem
makrobiotisch in Reifen Jahren
hört zu ganz genau kannten mich
an sie heran
aber da kann es schon mal gesagt
Vettel muss auch Button weiß
wie arbeitete seit warnte die
Leckerei nicht die Armen ärmer
Uhr bisschen Dormagen nur
drüber und dann noch wenn al
Gromer Zero Diskussionen
FC Sarnen Gewürzen Europäer so
müssen etwa in China oder Iran
ferner müsse so ersten gewesen
wenn wir das so war
man muss sich mal mit genau das
ist unsere Autos aus sein
Gedanken Strukturen unseres
billigste ist dann doch beim
Werne Prozent in dem Band and
Food -bereich das stimmt nicht
und
auch die Rechnung gemacht es
geht nicht auf weil es billigste
geht auf Kosten von uns allen
Branchen
per Konter bin ich natürlich
auf klar kann ich mit
Solarzellen aufs Dach machen
aber auch das ist ein
Rechenbeispiel in zehn Jahren
hat sich das wieder
aber genau dort wo man mit der
Wartung Kraft die ist im Moment
bin ich
aber die FATF lange nicht
unbezahlbar aber trotzdem wird
gemacht hatten entließen die
erste Frage die die beiden
Kinder meine Kinder die Männer
bezahlen kann am Sonntag
also diesen Gedanken dass
Prozent Unterrichtes ver di
nicht verstehen einer Seite www
alle Atome Spannung aber Energie
und so weiter ob
Geschichte
und anderseits
ob er das machen will
Jahres bis dem Problem der
Strahl 12 000 Jahre in dem
Moment da sein und dich
schlechte Idee dass etwas neues
einfallen Nein sagt er
ja okay es nicht so gut aber
keiner fühlen sich die anderen
drum das ist
Puma
11 und das Auto mal bewusst
ausgeführte
der Ausläufer einer Phase in
der man darf also bitte Dr
Entscheider die diese sind sie
endlich diese unverschämte Tode
richtige Entscheidung getroffen
haben wir können ja noch so
blöd sein dass in der Fachleute
andere Politiker wird im
WirtschaftsBlatt Leute die
studiert haben daran dass teuer
die kleinere keinen Plan haben
Nein
die Grammy Awards und wenn
bewegt eines natürlich selber
umweltbewegte
der Mann der keinen Plan die tun
nur alle so alt werden Tiere sie
bleibe die kleine Lawine und
begrub
egal dass das Wort darüber
sprechen wir nicht und das hier
ist ein nicht ganz so schlimm
aber
die haben alle kein Plan Alter
Schwede wird ganz schön
Kraus daraus einen Sonne
scheinen Kontrolle
wenn wir immer alles im Griff
hat
da kann ich halt Morgen Radu
stellte Super mein Kater zu
besiegen
World Blogging neue Leuchten
Jahre wird immer wieder durch
ein Bürgergeld von der dachte
ich mir auch vielleicht hatten
wir das noch nie unter Kontrolle
weil der Mensch fühlt sich
jetzt als würden die Kontrolle
genommen
aber eines ist sicher und so
das sei was auch gar nie so will
und so ein Gerät in Verdacht
nur immer wir hätten sie im
Griff
als ich Kind war
dachte ich
wenn ich mal erwachsen werden
aber so wie die anderen da
das ist dann irgendwie muss es
uns durch seinen wachst du auf
sondern dass du alles im Griff
und weiß Bescheid
weil die haben alles im Griff
von diesen bescheiden ich bin
deshalb noch ein Kind
und dann während meines Lebens
jetzt mit 42 immer noch
festzustellen «Ich bin immer
noch hier sogar aus und denkt
Mittersill abgeschminkt wir
haben hier alles im Griff aber
die anderen auch» sie alle
unter diesen immer so getan und
dann doch auch die Blaugrana
Dankeschön übers bringt sogar
bei Kindern bei
die nur ein als die und
das was sie erzählen weiß dass
er weiter «Fest» Scheich Sadiq
für Pechstein z
das müsse lernen
wir haben jetzt noch mal klar ob
er Klage überlegt
Hälfte keine sensationell
Aktion von einem zwölfjährigen
der Akzent die Aktion gestartet
wird auch darüber zu reden
pflanzt Bäume und er erklärt
angefangen Millionen Bäume auf
der Welt der Pflanzen ab von der
UNO schon geredet und da sage
ich genau
die jungen 10 12 13 14 15 Jahren
ihr müsst anfangen erwachsen zu
sagen
Pohle Hase lang läuft ihr
der Deal ist es auch klar aber
das hängt ja auch das ist ja so
einfach
als die Gäste
Moll auch der Manipulationen in
den Ligen die du als Kind schon
aufgetischt sich dass diese
Haase dass Zagreb
da was zu Ostern gibt es gleich
Interessierte bei der AWS das
auch schon immer gegessen sagt
der Pfarrer das setze aber das
kommt
sein wenn die Verniedlichung von
Tieren Schweine Stofftiere und
so
auf der anderen Seite
ich Weine auf dem Laster hier
gibt es frisches Fleisch innen
lustiges Schweigen als Metzger
Volk leidet steht auf diesem
Belag der Investor egal
neuer Leader Regeneration
während der ORF ist das wie
berauscht
für mich war als Tochter der
Baum wird keine Tiere Essen muss
sie auch fürchten dass die
einzige ist in der Schule die
das macht
mit 7 alle anderen
«Wie willst du das auch lernen
als Kind Wende von vornherein
damit aufs als leicht
Carlos ist doch egal
und da muss mal dann auch mal
raus muss irgendwann
wenn es das gibt Erwachsenwerden
und sich im klaren machen ca
klar werden was aber meine
Eltern erzählt wie viel davon
war Schrott
und jetzt neue meine eigenen
Gedanken zu machen aber auch die
wenigsten
im Leben lang sind die Eltern
Schuld der Partner die anderen
Sieg immer ein der nicht Schuld
dass seine eigenen Misere
das ist
dort müsst euch auch
abschminken
wir müssen zur Abstufung
absolut
Anwohner war Schussfahrt
abschminken einen Abwehrfehler
der Kaplan man kann es ist ein
Marienfeld Jane Fernsehen langen
Nacht im Tor machen
Hellmuth Buhr Anwältin auch der
verhinderte Festspielredner
separat
das ist wirklich das Problem und
ich finde Super ich finde es
möglich auch ich hier
auf den Punkt gebracht
ich kann es auch ich bin diese
Punkte fehlten ihr auch hier
Bahn nicht wegen höherer noch
schöner
den Schlüssel abgedunkelt
Bewerbung für eine enger als
bisher
und so nennen kann und sich
damit auseinandersetzen und sich
seine eigenen Gedanken machen
und ich glaube
alles schon viel erwartet am Set
machte den eigenen Gedanken
Adobe
mehr kannst du nicht
und schulischen hören
hier hat
ja danke schön bayer-abwehr
nun aber viel mehr